[موسيقى]
نعم اوافق ان الزواج واحد اكبر مني في
الصين طالما في حكم هي اللي يمنعليش
كرامتي ان انا اتجوز واحده اكبر مني لان
انا سنه صغير فالجوز واحده اكبر مني ليه
شخصي لا ما احبش كده
لازم احس ان انا مثلا في فرق ما بيني وما
بينها في السن على الاقل خمس ست سنين عشان
مستوى التفكير والحياه والدنيا والكلام ده
كله عادي جدا ممكن في واحده تحبني بحكم ان
انا اتعامل معها او كجر ليها او كده شافت
مني خلق طيب شافت مني حاجات كويسه في عملي
شافت من الالتزام او انضباط فبالتالي تعجب
بيا وانا اوافق على الزواج منها ادام هي
انت هتديني الحنان والحب والاحترام فما
فيش مشكله خالص التوافق الفكري ما بين
الطرفين مش هيكون
متناسب يعني وكده
فانا مش موافق ان انا اتجوز سته اكبر مني
حتى لو كنت بحبك وكده طالما احنا متفاهمين
ده اهم حاجه بغض النظر عن السن بس اهم
حاجه برده ان هو ما يبقاش بقى يعني 20 سنه
و30 سنه لا يبقى فيه حاجات مشتركه ما
بيننا يبقى في حياه ما بينا خلاص ما عنديش
مشكله عادي يعني طبعا ما فيش اي مشكله ولو
حصل بيني وبينكشن وهي انسانه عندها
المبادئ اللي انا ممكن احترمها او كده ليه
لا طبعا عادي ايه المشكله
[موسيقى]